some nice fabric oh god I hope I'm oh
god I hope I blend in oh I hope you
don't it will be super obvious if I'm
not blended in did you become one of the
piles of concrete no God is like
floating in space here I'm in a pile of
something ooh that's interesting
I'm just spectating right now okay
bother I see nothing giving you a clue
see nothing what's black and round and
filled with nothing ha ha ha ha bad
racist jokes what that was not at all
wave are you gonna be like that so it's
not a toilet no is that black and round
I guess not it's about Oh
barrel thing no blagging around I'm
black and round you a black hole marks
hair yield oh my god there are so many
chairs in this room oh I'm not in that
room Bob I'm making this easy because
it's one on two I'm not in that room
black and round
Oh I'm black and round not a barrel and
filled with nothing it's filled with
nothing
are you a tire don't worry I don't know
how to get outside this side I'm
rubberized this tires going on the road
member
[Music]
me use it there why'd you go inside you
just made me faceplant on to my mic that
was unbelievable God yeah that huge
clunk most me face-planting my mic and
then like that'll be good for the webcam
oh yeah the rule you've gotta like gotta
stay mobile when it's just dust right
that was a rule gotta move around we got
to move around can't stay in the same
place boys I'm gonna get you where are
you where are you sons of [ __ ]
Oh someone's a chair ray did I hear
something someone in the bathroom are
you being so tough guys where are you
thing where are you why are you being so
uh totally silent
ah no particular reason someone in this
okay it's how you stepped on me mark
where are you I don't know where are you
hiding
I smell you I'm I'm maze paper Mel you
see I hear you I smell you in this room
no Ron Schara wait I don't need your
help
actually now I don't know where he went
I smell yes densha yeah
Oh mark you were so close but you barely
made it away from you there merrily
[Laughter]
no no where you ain't nothing and never
gonna be no lied yet I was next to that
barrel you shot I was not the barrel
that you shot I was on the floor hiding
behind it
now I'm going outside go through go
through the garage door and I'll play
with you really outside when I wake
myself up oh I can become that I'm just
having fun with you having fun doing
what I around someone really well did
you think that everyone in the comments
below will agree that it was a pretty
sick and twisted maneuver that I pulled
also clutch huh wow that's interesting
wait is one of you outside cuz if one of
your outside that's gonna really mess up
with my plans that's baloney
oh my god you can become that I know I
love this level what are you talking
about what can you become what you don't
know I was chasing you've liked the last
couple minutes away from you you're
gonna find me I slipped away from you
there I slipped away I saw you my heart
of hearts I won that round I think
degree let's both be this oh my gosh
alright just line up like there just
like right there and I'm with you and
what are you guys hmm what are you what
are you wanna hit me in not really a
little Hootie getting tired of your
questioning
Oh a little honey honey honey honey this
is a really roundabout way of begging
lark a little edgy hoody honey
oh no do you think you any more hints
are you in the game yet or what mark
know where I'm no where is no everywhere
we're actually hi you saw nothing
there's one tough blonde man well let's
see I liked our first idea better where
we we should do that other spot and line
up like that yeah which one I think I've
broken everything I know I think he's
just jerking us around
no I'm not I wish I was there we go
that's better
I guess he's probably just something
really tiny running around like a real
douche bag you're gonna laugh when you
find out what I was oh I'm stuck again
oh hey buddy yeah I'm okay was he I was
this oh no I'm inside you are you inside
my own aha
I've got to now I literally asked you to
do in my drop now dancing on mark always
freak it out the Adar die because of
that
okay where are you guys gonna be uh not
too far but not too close
oh my gosh I didn't actually want to
become that that was bad yeah oh no no
no no yeah yeah yeah no yeah no yeah no
how about yeah no no wait help yeah help
yes
having my own problems here well oh well
this is awkward
[Music]
[Laughter]
you see nothing something happened in
this for a month wait do you see what I
am yes tell him what tell him what was
wrong with his little disguise they're
facing the wrong way you're a completely
perpendicular from where you were
supposed to be don't understand the
mechanic of how that thing faces I think
you always face it the direction that
you pick that's what I did
oh maybe not maybe it's always the same
way oh how it works
I don't either oh I was just a ghost on
the toilet oh come on
not again oh hey marks outside god damn
it shut up
you'll never find me I got stuck again
you'll never find me
really you'll never find me you'll never
find me are you just standing at the end
just to block me from going around yes
why why do such a thing
I'm nowhere and I'm everywhere I'm in
your dreams and in your pants and you'll
never see me coming you'll never know
what are you know you'll never see me
come do you see us no yes no no no was
he he was a bucket hiding in the shadows
in the corner oh it was all I could do
you [ __ ] are just dicks and eat lots
of crap are you sons of [ __ ] you
don't give me a chance did we buy by
yourself
oh this isn't what I meant to pick ah
well this is awkward
is it tell me more I don't want son of a
damn it - yeah yeah yeah that's what I
like to hear
yes struggle struggle oh toggle oh no oh
no I want to know if I look like what
I'm supposed to or not I don't think I
did
oh no no oh damn it are you doing hey
I'll get you sitting there with your
bowl of cereal what I'm trying to get
out of the thing what's more sir there
is laughs did you go outside to mark are
you out here with us
don't why I mean yeah followed you out
oh my gosh we're so quiet
hey silently moving boxes around I hear
it he just destroyed why has never been
throughout a video I can't believe this
worked
I can't believe mine worked I'm not even
hidden who my mark you're so bad mark
hush hi mark
Oh mark autumn marks in you literally
look right at me
you won by me twice and I'm the worst
spot ever
hush I'm in an accident which would you
stop doing that stop it and here we just
can't get really close to our
microphones and chitchat hey hush come
find me mark Rach Rach shelving unit bra
theater wait that spot is horrible I
know he ran by me two or three times
Oh mark you're doing it wrong mark
you're doing it wrong
[Laughter]
you look really good
[Music]